the future of furniture is here and it
turns out to be a little bit less Herman
Miller and a little bit more
transformers scientists in Switzerland
have developed these little Goths they
call them room BOTS they are robots
shaped like two cubes that can move
around and autonomously assemble to
create furniture for now they're
pre-programmed or operated with a remote
control but scientists are also
developing software that allows the
robots to learn where to go on their own
inside each robot is a battery and three
motors that allow it to pivot gripper
latches allow them to connect to one
another climb up a wall or grab anything
that has special notches they could be a
big help to the disabled for elderly
people who can't easily move which is
what the scientists had in mind but
there is real potential for innovative
applications from reconfigurable meeting
places to art however scientists still
need to smooth out how the robots move
and more importantly figure out how
users can control them so while this
does look like a glimpse into the future
researchers don't expect robots to be on
the market for another 20 years